Donald Trump yesterday had a press
availability I guess we would call it at
the White House it this was before Iran
attacked two US military bases in Iraq
and it was a strange sort of gongshow
combination of rambling confusing and
dishonest and it's becoming increasingly
embarrassing to be a trump supporter now
to normal people that is I I think
within their you know cult Trump
supporters were doing within the world
of the cult Trump supporter they're
probably still pretty outwardly happy
with their choice at least as far as
they're willing to admit but when you
see Donald Trump behave in this way make
no sense tell lies inaccuracies look
confused and disheveled this has to be
embarrassing for a Trump supporter right
or are they so cognitively dissonant
that they even see this and think wow
that's who I'm voting for for
re-election let's look at some clips
Donald Trump was first asked what did
you know about soleimani when you
decided to assassinate him and this is
an important question because we've
since learned since the assassination
we've learned that Donald Trump
essentially knew nothing about Kaseem
soleimani
but he was reportedly talked into the
assassination by some of the people
around him even though it had originally
been presented by the Pentagon as quote
the crazy option that they were offering
not expecting that he would take it and
Donald Trump confirms it in this first
clip he really knew nothing about Kaseem
soleimani Eric about what evidence you
had the Qasem Soleimani was planning
attacks against American targets what
can you tell us about what you knew
prior to or during the attack well
number one I knew the past his past was
horrible he was a terrorist he was so
designated by President Obama as you
know and he wasn't even supposed to be
outside of his own country he was so
right there but that's in a way the
least of it we had an attack very
recently that he was in charge of where
we had people horribly wounded one dead
in fact the number now as of this
morning I believe is two dead and that
was his
was traveling with the head of Hezbollah
they weren't there to discuss a vacation
they weren't there to go to a nice
resort someplace in Baghdad they were
there to discuss bad business and we
saved a lot of lives by terminating his
life a lot of lives have saved they were
planning something and you're going to
be hearing about it or at least various
people in Congress are going to be
hearing about it tomorrow our Secretary
of State covered it very well a little
while ago I saw him I saw his news
conference but so this is the same
razor-thin justification that they've
been parroting for several days and
you'll see later in a clip with Mike
Pompeo that they've already shifted to a
different justification for the Kasim
soleimani assassination but we'll get to
that Donald Trump then in the same press
avail is asked about his threat of war
crimes Donald Trump remember on Twitter
threatening to target Iranian cultural
heritage sites and here's what he had to
say mr. president whether irani and
cultural sites would be on any future
target well as I said yesterday was very
interesting they're allowed to kill our
people they're allowed to maim our
people they're allowed to blow up
everything that we have and there's
nothing to stop them and we are
according to a various laws supposed to
be very careful with their cultural
heritage and you know what if that's
what the law is I like to obey the law
but think of it they kill our people
they blow up our people and then we have
to be very gentle with their cultural
institutions but I'm ok with it it's ok
with me oh these laws they say we have
to be so careful we have to be gentle
but importantly notice that Donald Trump
is now backtracking saying ok we will
obey the law
I guess the war crimes have been
canceled by Donald Trump good thing
yesterday I told you that the Pentagon
immediately said yeah Trump's suggesting
we target Iranian cultural sites we
wouldn't do that
the Pentagon immediately saying that's
not something that they would do then it
got really weird as if what we've seen
so far isn't weird enough Donald Trump
was asked about the Greek population in
the United
States check out what he had to say say
so Greece and I and my people and we
have a whole group of people and as you
see they've brought a lot of great
representatives from Greece that we've
been dealing with
we have a tremendous Greek population
over three million people as I
understand it that's fantastic I think I
know I really feel I know most of them I
think I know all of them come to think
of it but it's a great population in the
United States we're gonna be meeting
we're going to be talking we're gonna be
negotiating and we're gonna be making a
lot of deals Greece and I I love that at
greet he talks about Greece and I the
Greek population is tremendous now a
quick fact check there are not three
million Greek people in the United
States the number is less than half that
1.4 million Americans are of Greek
descent now that can be sort of vague
only about 320,000 people in the u.s.
above age five speak Greek at home as of
a few years ago but never let the facts
get in the way of a good hyperbolic
ramble and then Donald Trump for good
measure
repeats the complete and total lie that
he was strongly against the Iraq war
remember he was not strongly against the
Iraq war but here is Donald Trump
repeating this yet again let's see we
don't want to be there forever we want
to be able to get out I didn't want to
be there in the first place to be honest
and everybody knows that now that was
when I was a civilian I said it but we
were there and they made a decision and
I disagreed with that decision very
strongly but we're there now we've done
a great job we've gotten rid of the
caliphate 100% of the caliphate is gone
now here is Donald Trump saying that he
was in favor of the Iraq war on the
Howard Stern Show in 2002 I've played
this clip for you before and it is
particularly relevant here you know
they're skulking around somewhere and
you just feel like you're sitting dog
but we have an idea with the enemies and
a lot of times the politicians don't
want to tell you that are you for
invading Iraq yeah I guess so
you know I wish it was
wish the first Apple is done correctly
are you still against rebuilding the
World Trade Center I'm not a guest
rebuilding yeah I said very clearly not
a guy who was against the Iraq war
so it's exhausting to keep up with it
all it never makes any sense it's a mess
it's a worldwide laughingstock and
meanwhile Donald Trump always seems to
be a few talking points behind on these
things because now Donald Trump's own
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo has come
up with a new justification for
assassinating Kasim Soleimani that's
actually even more incoherent than the
one Trump gave remember the initial
justification for the assassination of
the Iranian codes leader that started
this entire thing including two US
military bases being bombed last night
was a justification based on the
imminency of an attack plan by Kasim
soleimani based on what he was doing now
and Donald Trump parroted that during
his press avail but then here is Mike
Pompeo talking about oh no the
justification is attacks that took place
sometimes in the past which is a
completely different explanation the
opportunity that we thought might
present itself at some point and we
could see clearly that not only had
sulemani done all of the things that we
have recounted right hundreds of
thousands of massacre in Syria enormous
destruction of countries like Lebanon
and Iraq where they've denied them
sovereignty in the Iranian have really
denied people in those two countries
what it is they want right sovereignty
independence that freedom is this is all
Soleimani Zandi work and then we'd watch
as he was continuing the terror campaign
in the region we know what happened at
the end of last year in December
ultimately to the death of an American
so a shift from it was an imminent
threat which has been widely debunked
because there was no evidence of
presented with that - this was really
more punishment for things that were
done in the past the reason they can't
get their stories straight is because
none of the stories make sense and this
was all framed up as an attempt by
Donald Trump to distract from
impeachment and - as he sees it helped
him in his re-election campaign in an
election that is now just about ten and
a half months away this is going to
continue getting worse
unless an adult can get into the room
and make sure that it doesn't it's not
clear that that's going to happen we'll
keep following it and by the time you
listen to or watch this clip Trump may
have bombed Iran we just cannot predict
what is going to happen next I want to
tell you about a really great YouTube
channel we're partnering with it's
called up flip TV and they've just
recently launched they've have some
excellent content for anybody interested
in business and entrepreneurship check
them out at david pakman.com slash flip
that's f li p
that'll redirect you to their youtube
channel make sure to subscribe while
you're there it is a YouTube channel
that I'd recommend to anyone in the
David Pakman show audience who owns a
business runs a business it's thinking
about starting a business or even if you
just like learning new things about how
business works they interview successful
entrepreneurs business owners giving
them a place to tell their stories and
share strategies so viewers can benefit
from their insight and apply their
wisdom to your own businesses all of the
content is about educating and inspiring
people in each video up flip TV
showcases a different type of startup it
could be a coffee shop or a landscaping
business or a real estate agency you'll
see how the business was often started
from scratch what a workday looks like
how to become and remain successful in
that business and they don't just
interview people they actually examine
each business from inside out in a
really unique way that distills the
valuable lessons that you can take from
their stories I find the content
fascinating they're friends of the David
Pakman show I would love it if you would
go and support their new YouTube channel
and what they're doing I think you'll
very quickly become a fan like I said
get there by going to david pakman.com
slash flip
that's FL IP and make sure to subscribe
to their channel when you're there